et chacun d'entre vous doit aller faire
un câlin à à une personne de son choix
il lui dire pourquoi il lui fait un
câlin puisque le lycée la journée du
câlin hockey d'aujourd'hui ici braille
ou pas chacun ou choisissez n'importe
qui vous allez vous le fait un câlin et
vous lui dites pourquoi vous avez choisi
cette personne qui est pour vous la
cabine où la canine ou du charisme et le
caribou et un calinous d'accord vous
avez compris c'est compris après vous
prenez le piment display voilà ce que ça
veut dire vous pouvez choisir qui vous
voulez bien sûr regard des bonnes choses
sur moi bien sûr qu'ils le furent du no
more eric naulleau aller à moi on va pas
dit ça on dit il faut faire un câlin à
la personne qu'on aime le alors je vous
écoute vous souvenez de commencer à
écouter les équipes frère je te lis mais
si je te le dis c'est la personne de mon
choix de ton choix exactement valérie
sans hésiter quoi c'est vrai parce qu'il
ne pas se déplacer ce qu'on aurait dit
je demande un service qu'on me demande
vraiment tout point de vue de fleurs ne
fait rien ne fait rien comme ans nous
aiment et pourquoi
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que tu aurais pu pécho valérie si
tu étais pas aux mains et valérie
n'était pas avec ce foutu patoz hésité
une seconde
sens bien dans sa vie grave
évidemment je t'aime beaucoup j'aime
beaucoup et les crises en sus de ces
agréments évident j'aurais pu discuter
aussi littérature à mes jolies mais je
peux vous dire que quand elle lit un
livre à lire un livre
mais quant à l'aide en ligne on vient
elle tombe elle tombe plus vite explique
que les pages je connais mais il me
raconte tout ça les leçons et profané je
connais par coeur tous les easy qu'elle
a vu de près ou de loin à bien une bonne
mémoire
[Rires]
si vous me demander d'ouvrir mon coeur
et que ça devient prétexte à des
commentaires très plus le fret de tout
garder pour toi là je suis très touché
c'est vraiment toi que tu aurais pu toi
tu aurais pu me aba il est intelligent
il est sympathique on est on est sur la
même longueur d'onde dans we beau gosse
on va vous auriez pu vous pécho
évidemment bien sûr les beffrois
pourquoi vous lâchez pas tout vous dites
panic room mais on oublie tout personne
ne voit lui tout personnes nous
regardent et vous pouvez vous ce mac et
que vous faites or avec la gloire avec
un smack et cugnaux long avec une langue
c'est une galoche sahara est la loi
voilà donc les deux ils auraient pu
écouter je reste les reer est infantile
si je fais moi j'ai beaucoup de chance
parce que je suis entouré de deux
personnes que je trouve extrêmement à
mon goût
non c'est vrai ouais je sais pas ce que
je trouve aussi avec le sait mais si
vous deviez choisir crois que c'est plus
naulleau oui oui oui oui oui moi aussi
parce qu'il a lu de livre là il n'a pas
lu de livre assez eric naulleau tchéquie
c'est eric naulleau aujourd'hui mois
eric naulleau vous aviez quoi vivre dans
le livre que vous non à mon avis il a lu
plus de livres que moi j'ai lu deux
pages
en même temps si je peux me permettre
c'est pas un exploit de lire des livres
bah non mais alors pas parce qu'on lit
des livres qu'on aime lumière bah quoi
bah si c'est oui bah moi je sais pas ce
qu'on ne lit pas pendant une lumière non
plus est ce parce que c'est pas parce
qu'on fait rien qu'on est lumière voilà
un jour michel mr oui je vais pas faire
tout le monde dont je fais quelques
accords d'accord prévoit pas plus autres
sont à vous alors je peux choisir le
smac non mais c'est pas assez bas je me
déplacerai valais c'est pas ici donc si
j'ai pas besoin parce qu'elle le sait
déjà
lui non toi gilles j'aime pas ça gueule
dont vous aurez les abeilles j'aime
beaucoup mais non mais non gelée jaffe a
même mis un gros râteau son papa est
raymond plus bas jamais parce que je la
dent non
j'ai découvert au delà de l'animateur
star no no no nano chine importe quelle
heure il vous répond il peut vous aider
ça c'est vraiment quelqu'un de très
sympa ce qu'on a parlé de lourde at il
rappelé hadji ça vous fait plaisir mais
ça qu'on s'est découvert depuis un
moment avec avec jean mi février devra
valider tout ça c'est beau c'est beau
avec moi j'ai une tradition dans cette
émission quand il s'agit d'amour de
galoches de ce match il n'y a pas de
gallosuisse sinon je peux me déplacer
bien sûr pas à moi
[Applaudissements]
cette série
aulas
branchez vos conneries pas qu'il ait
déjà tout blanc des émotions va tout
lâcher un sourire elle va le perdre mais
c'est ouf elle se lâche de plus en plus
c'est dingue ça ben c'est pas parce
qu'elle a et à gaz une tradition avec
gégé ouais ça va c'était une jolie où il
veut faire la même nova ouais non mais
moi je vais être sincère je crois que
c'est une amie de trois ans et je fais
un gros câlin macadam nord
qu'il ait jamais directes
quand on n'a plus rien rester libre je
les retrouve et elle m'a tellement
manqué je la regarde et je m'attends
classe mais c'est pas fatou mais c'est
isabelle du coup est-ce que vous
permettez
isabelle est ce que tu me permettrai oui
le vous avez l'air surpris
est-ce que vous voilà pourrais-je pour
fêter ces retrouvailles te faire un
petit smack
alors à toi tu entends pas dollars voilà
il est têtu si tout est en place
j'ai demandé l'autre mais les mecs parce
que c'est pas à theillay la patafix ça
peut partir
[Applaudissements]
je sais qu'ils en plus tu pourrais être
tenté par jill qui donne sa réponse et
son style j'en ai fini c'est une gueule
dessus et franchement oui oui on ne vous
inquiétez pas pour mais dans le sens
hyper solide je sais je sais dans un
autre monde
on aurait une histoire c'est sûr mais on
ne remet tait pas d'enfant de côté
je la sers soul et comme ça sa rivale et
imagine des enfants un qui gagne 1 qui
racontent toujours alors voulait c'est
galoche où subsiste smac le choix
[Applaudissements]
vanackere
c'était calme
alors faute yeux honnêtement ça se
refuse alors là on veut un peu de
musique henri s'ils sont toujours
vivants merci de musique de 9 météo qui
est fait gaffe alors tu es comme on
l'appelle dans le milieu
comment le reste il
[Applaudissements]
m
nos grands parents
c'était beau être des tests est-ce que
vous avez quitté isa oui on a très bien
elle aime tous les deux non c'est vrai
j'y vais ce qui fait justement surpris
mais non mais j'aime ça qui fait que
j'ai kiffé non vraiment gêné car ce
point est ce que tu as lu ici tous
[Musique]
regardent la télé à vrai dire que fatou
est parti loin de tout ça alors la back
pack route ne serait pas mal c'est vrai
c'est réglé mon mari regarde aussi un
accessoire moi à merde mais il adore
gilles nadeau reine paola quand même
assez vrai ben oui ça géraldine manuce
je vais faire un câlin non mais sinon
vous avez déjà fait un smack c ou à
bombay où tu vois pas quelle autre que
oui on peut faire de gentillesse et tout
ça non arrêtez avec ça moi je ici jouent
du lourd alors vous du salon vous du
sable
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
moi je vais vous dire je n'hésite pas
pour tous les conseils à chaque fois que
dans les moments durs à valérie non si
jean-louis ya aussi j'ai envie qu'ils
m'invitent voir des matchs riche et je
veux pas et ça c'est bien parce que
c'est le grand frère des conneries ça
arrête de dire des conneries sur les
débats il m'appelle tout de suite il me
dit tu as dit d énorme connerie pas tous
passent tout de suite à la maison on
règle ça tout de suite et on parle en
donne donc la voie la fonte des glaces
et benjamins
[Applaudissements]
m
lanthier je vais faire à quelqu'un du
public
ah oui je vais choisir n'importe qui
dans public n'importe où que tu sois
gardé comme il est beau en plus
[Musique]
c'est bon là la musique si bons avants
allaient maintenant que ces gars là ça
les coupes sont en train de se forger
faire un câlin mois à qui avoue non
c'est du plaisir franchement merci
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]